good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast like my good friend
Rebecca black once said it's Friday
Friday gotta eat my feelings on Friday
but I eat my feelings every day so even
though this was a short week this Friday
is so I'm so excited for this Friday I
feel this morning and I was just like
one more day until I can sleep in but it
feels like we didn't earn this Friday
they did like we've done great shows we
have in hard having a model on the show
today yes super citizen a super model
some would say Emily didn't Otto and I
think what makes her so town Abuk I said
she's a toaster yeah it's like that's
all you need like beautiful on the
outside and the inside and I have so
much I need to talk to her about like
the corruption of the modeling industry
and I feel like she's like so into and
was like what's going on I totally agree
um do I look different to you um yes
what looks different it's just your aura
oh my god
I was literally gonna say my aura that's
so weird it's almost like we're sisters
um I'm a different person that I was
what why you look so different wiser or
a different because I've been talking
about like what for like two weeks about
my obsession with the vlog squad right
like I just have recently I know I'm
like the last person on earth to like
become obsessed with them but I have and
I bought merch and I'm wearing it today
and I've been waiting for the right
moment to wear it but today was
definitely the right moment to wear my
merch because why would today be the
right day to wear the merch
schecky I'm so glad you asked because
today is the first day where we have
come in contact with the vlog squad I
had a feeling that you know maybe one or
two of the female members might be a
toaster maybe you know follow girl with
no job and we found her and she's the
best one her name is Erin she's so
pretty and she has red hair and she's
engaged so she has like a really stable
home life and she's also like crazy with
the vlog squad which we totally
appreciate a balanced homework life and
I just need you all to go watch her
Instagram story because we have our own
filter if you haven't used it yet you
totally should shout out to Kevin who
made it it's which scene are you and
like the thing flashes on Instagram
really accurate except I've literally
never got myself I always get American
camper I mean everyone has a bit of
American camper in them there
she is everyone everyone is her so it
says which Jean are you in flashes
between like all of us been Zak W Zak s
like all the dumb names we've come up
with everything nervous to see I know oh
he was gonna get like French camper
because it looks just like a stupid like
he doesn't go yeah yeah so Aaron put
david dobrik on her Instagram story
doing our filter and he's like reading
and he's like what sistene which is such
a relatable question it's like nobody
really knows what the scene is and he
ended up getting Ben and it was just
like the best moment of my life I got
literally screen recording it and I've
watched it 75 times since and I just
feel like we're getting like much closer
to TMT vlog squad crossover that's why I
decided to wear my merch today I know
like you'd spot change like you know
every influencers not afraid but no I
paid for it fan joy fifty dollars and I
was very proud to support I really like
it I oh so cute right yeah that's cute
Mart yeah I want to seal it no I
definitely need to find out what company
the sweater is like it's a good one yeah
last night we also went to the Yahoo
sham young leadership gala we did and by
the way they I forgot that we
participated in their raffle which was
two tickets to a live taping of the
morning toast which is actually
something that money can't buy it's
priceless so when thinking about where
to start the silent bid they start
started a silent auction at 400 dollars
which I thought was cheaper the price I
think also meant to go up but also it's
for charity so you pay you overpay
because you're donating to charge right
and Yad Vashem is just you know working
tirelessly at not letting the stories of
the Holocaust be forgotten so we're
happy to be a part of it right that
can't put a price on not letting stories
of the Holocaust be forgotten no there's
really no price to put on the Holocaust
unless it was a busy night for me
because I was double booked because I
had my dinner book club that's how it
happens and it was the second monthly
book club and even though I had to go to
Yad Vashem like I just didn't feel like
I could cancel because once you disrupt
the sanctity of the book club then
anyone can cancel and once you like to
stir up the flow of like the next month
if you had missed it like they would
have been like they would have forgotten
about you yeah and everyone really
appreciated that I did double duty but
even my friend Britt was like my parents
had tickets to the show but I was like I
can't I have my book line so it's a huge
commitment yes so I was able to do both
I was so happy about it by missed you at
the gala but I did see you in the street
I was in my car shouting girl with no
job girl and I was like who is very much
printing oh no I didn't I was just like
freezing and I was like someone really
calling my name from a car and then
actually so wait so crazy I was a me and
bed got an uber went home
we're walking into our building someone
in a yellow cab of a street it's like
girl though job like jockeys are you it
was actually a true fabulous I just
follow you around and vehicles so we
show for you guys Fast Five Emily didn't
Auto merch everything yeah also the book
for the book club was a book of se
overall I think we all agreed it was
about a 2.5 on the scale of 5 Wow yeah
it works
it wasn't um it wasn't my favorite I'm
wearing like a bear thigh on the show
today which is just a brave thing for me
to do but I'm looking at my phone is
looking quite quite hot I think that
like we haven't been inspired by Emily
didn't Otto say because obviously like I
wanted to wear my Friday I mean you
literally look like I didn't intend to
look so professional you then it just
happened you look like the top agent and
a modeling agency Wow and I'm choosing
Emily did not have her yeah no I didn't
mean to wear [ __ ] but with everything
else I wanted to wear just a simple tank
but I've said ever since I clean out my
apartment and I guess simple tanks
didn't spark joy for me I threw them all
away and now I don't have any simple
tanks nobody really chooses though to
wear a [ __ ] bow it just kind of happens
on your yak it does and it's just like
the day look at this when you look
outside that you think I need to wear a
[ __ ] bow I wonder if our video on
YouTube will get demonetized today for
saying [ __ ] well so many times
[ __ ] boy [ __ ] boy [ __ ] boy [ __ ] boy
[ __ ] boy [ __ ] boy [ __ ] boy sounds
like Placido yeah also I know we said
that we have a great show for you today
but and we do and we do but not as great
as usual because our third co-host is
not here Theodore for chairman it's
taking the day off he's getting an early
start on the weekend yeah he decided to
take a long weekend he's going out to
the Hamptons
I heard that him and Emily did not
actually have beef you know actually
wanted to bring him just so Emily could
meet her but feels very disruptive when
we have guests so he's very much a
mainstay on the show so obsessed with
her that like all he would do would be
like sniffing jump around and it's like
the only professional cool
no but I did hear that they had beef but
I'm happy here that you but I'm happy to
hear they got it was beef with everyone
except for me okay are you ready to get
into the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast yeah I
think I am I think I've said all that
needs to be said I'm not feeling RDH
this morning I've actually you know I
wasn't
eh for a few months but I'm feeling a
lot better this week I wonder what
happened so I'm good
great okay well the first story is
really crazy because Katy Perry has
collapsed on the American Idol set after
a propane leak
what People magazine reports that Katy
Perry and her fellow American Idol
judges Luke Bryan and Lionel Richie had
to evacuate the set of the show because
of a gas leak in a clip from the show
the singer Katy Perry miss Perry
miss Perry becomes increase because I
said singer but up there all singers
becomes increasingly well it said the
firework singer but I just hate
referring to people like that
um yeah because it's like a diminishment
of all their accomplishments even though
kitty Perry is the firework singer I
know but I'm just like she's just the
singer she's also she's just a girl you
know yeah like I would say the woman I
guess she's the only woman right the
female host yeah
becomes increasingly freaked out about a
strong cocaine smell until she
eventually picks up her things and makes
for the exit the clip shows her
complaining of a headache before
dropping to the ground as EMTs arrive
okay so this is a story it's gonna be a
storyline on the show yeah so I think
it's fake like if it was like they
didn't have any footage and they had to
like shut down production and kick
everyone out and then she ended up
collapsing that to me is like so real
this just seems like clickbait for
American Idol
yeah we're working overtime on their
marketing or maybe it's like they want
to warn America of the dangers of gas
leaks you know so they're just doing
some like subtle infomerge reminding
everyone to like change of batteries and
their co2 monoxide yeah Bieber's that's
always a good lesson always a good
lesson I mean this is uh this is such a
weird story
I feel like American Idol has been back
now for two this is the second season
right and to me like it seemed and I
watched a first season and I really
liked it but it seems so staged like I
never felt watching like the Kelly
Clarkson days like it was rigged at all
we were all so so young and so naive for
sure but to me there was like a
genuineness about like a hometown when
it's like we found out later that Gabby
Barrett who made it pretty far was
working with Luke Bryan his management
company already so like now I just have
that in my brain as like these
contestants are pre chosen and like the
whole the results are predetermined even
though the person who ended up winning
went nowhere the top two went nowhere
Gabby battered I think came in like
third or fourth yeah and to me she's the
only relevant one kaleb's Mady yeah Mady
and then her boyfriend Caleb I think
they're still together who came on our
show Gabby and her
husband are from American Idol chief and
they both got married yes it really has
a better success rate than The Bachelor
at this a thousand percent one of Gabbi
Derek's songs came up on my Lou Combs
radio it's called one of the good ones
and it's it's a great song good one of
the good ones it's a great one and then
one of her songs went viral on tick tock
which is um I hope you both feel spawns
bond again did the driver help you want
you're the one hand amended the nanohub
never ever fell more free and it's all
about like you know girls on tick-tock
who have been like mistreated by their
men it's like really sad but she's doing
quite well for herself and she didn't
win so she was like pre disposed to
being successful because she had already
linked up with Luke Bryan yeah but I
think that in this day and age like they
just like knowing they you know all
these variables that can go wrong they
want to know what's gonna happen when
you're putting on a major TV show like
American Idol and I kind of have that I
get that too but yeah he get up to
chance that's just the best singer in
the world is gonna walk through those
doors right and the way also what's
making me feel that way is that they're
now running commercials with Ryan
Seacrest like driving a bus full of
contestants when the show hasn't even
aired yet so they have like the top 20
in the commercial already yeah it's so
weird but maybe it makes it for a better
show maybe you know one of my favorite
things that they do on American Idol was
after Hollywood week and after there's
like maybe 20 people left they have all
of the contestants perform songs with
the person who sang it so I Katy Perry
did one they had Lea Michele do an
amazing performance and they get only
really top-tier musicians who know how
to say it like you know they're not
getting I'm not gonna slander anyone's
name but you know what I mean
and it's really beautiful it's like one
of my favorite things well definitely be
watching but I just watch it now under
the the mindset of it being super stage
and this article about Katy Perry is
just giving me that vibe to what they
happened to capture cat capture her
collapsing we have cameras everywhere it
just seems too convenient you know
interesting oh by the way wouldn't even
talk about how we got a new carpet oh
yeah I mean I think the vibes are just
they're so OnPoint
they're so light bright we have a brand
new white carpet from sofa via which
thanks for the carpets of Pavia and the
show actually pay for it I just thought
thanks for making it because by the way
I've been looking for a shiny white
carpet on every website overstock weight
fair I looked all through Jill Zarin
rugs and
nobody could find what I wanted this is
exactly what I wanted everyone imposes
like their prints on you yeah I'm like
their little you know shag rugs no I
just wanted a clean white carpet so
shadows just a phobia for making it
I love it I'm loving the set vibes me
too I'm I'm really feeling like we're
almost there
yeah we're waiting on one piece from our
couch but other than that I think we're
almost there
I want you to take us a little over a
month yeah I mean you can't put a
timeline and I am set on perfection yeah
okay next up Tyler Cameron builds insane
doghouse for Kyle Richards in his new
show so we're talking about his kwibi
show yesterday architecture but the
reset what the show is textured four
dogs
yes okay okay and I guess he's building
celebrity dog homes which is just so
nice but I also love it no it's the most
niche but yeah but I think I get a
contractor and he loves dogs and he's a
celebrity and it's like well how can we
put all these things into one and
celebrities love their dogs right wait I
didn't know that's what the show is and
I'm sorry that I ever said anything bad
about it because it sounds great yeah
Tyler Cameron will star in a new kwibi
series called Barca texture where he
builds custom dog houses for clients
including Kyle Richards in a new teaser
for the show The Bachelor star is
presenting an over-the-top mini modern
home for the pup of The Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills personality that's
unbelievable Richards it's clayton's as
she checks out the mutt mansion also
other clients in the show will be Lisa
Vanderpump Rumer Willis and Joel McHale
Jill we can I mean I love this it just
reminds me of what Paris Hilton has for
her dogs she's just sickening version of
her house for her dogs air conditioning
onic air conditioning you think that
like if you're a big star and you have
the money and you love dogs like there's
no reason why you shouldn't have a mini
home it's like what stormy has yeah she
has a mini version of Kylie's house no
this is so cute I love the idea for the
show I actually feel like I'm gonna
watch it Kyle Richards dogs I follow her
on Instagram they're just menaces like
they're always going on the pool cover
when they should it storm is always just
being out of control with the house
during the family photo shoot yeah they
ran out of the gates but now I think it
was because they didn't have their own
house probably they were out probably
leaving the gates to go look like they
had a meeting with their realtor they're
probably going there by the house we're
going to meet Tyler Cameron to put down
like the foundation going to meet
someone from the agency to fight in the
house but then they realize they should
just build it themselves if you want
something done right do it yourself and
if you build it they will come and then
so the dog said to each other which of
the episodes are only 10 minutes right
on kwibi
oh I thought I was the format is it I
don't know like I haven't done that much
investigation into it quick bites I
think oh yeah yeah um well when I think
of quick bites I think it more like a
catered affair yeah I love a quick bite
it's snackable item yet what I'm
thinking of what we're gonna be having
after the show today oh good bite I
think we have to have a long bite though
you know I think we need a Libby I'm so
hungry
I'm still on cheese on April 6 so I
guess we'll check back then totally I
think that's such a good idea I wish I
had known more about the show when we
interview Tyler because I would have
loved to have spoken to him about that
he was telling us a little bit about it
I don't remember folks on camera off
camera and it sounded cool and now I'm
glad to know that it is cool so you
think you're gonna subscribe to kwibi um
I need to know more about the the liner
is kwibi also a subscription it's an app
you download I feel like it's totally
subscription they're spending so much
money the streaming he masks the
streaming words great for the consumer
great for the consumer I'm excited I'm
gonna get HBO max and I think I'm gonna
get peacock - I'm gonna get I'm really
gonna get them all because I don't have
cable and this was made for me they're
doing it for me how can I not support
them all yeah it'll be rude of us not to
yeah and I feel like I have so many
streaming services that I use but I
don't personally pay for same thing
Google is Heights letting me use your
Hulu for the last few years Hulu Netflix
and so I'm ready to start you know
putting my money where my mouth is you
know what now that I think about it the
only thing I paid for like out of my own
pocket is Spotify which I would
literally pay three times as much for
it's the best I don't tell them I know
please don't raise your prices but just
know like if you made it a hundred
dollars a month I think I would still
pay for it because you know today I was
like me and Ben we're getting ready and
you know we're big five sauces number
one fan and they released a new song
today and they released a new song a few
weeks ago and Benes their big fan but
he's not like on top of music trends he
doesn't like following a music Friday so
I was just like hopping all around my
Spotify Avenue making it so easy they
knew exactly what I was looking for and
I couldn't remember the name of the song
but it just came right up I'm like Ben
listen to this new song their song no
shame is [ __ ] amazing that's the way
they had a music video for that Hannah
Lux Davis oh yeah it was yeah really
interesting I don't really get it but I
don't think you were supposed to get it
and I just love 5 seconds of summer and
I hope that if I talked about them
enough on this show like maybe someone
will send me like a backstage pass to
one of their shows love it yeah maybe
also I
playing you know I thought that spot if
I had one error in it because when you
go to search for a song and you just
want to play one song I wanted to hear
she got the best of me because I saw
that video then they'll play next songs
she's got this yes she got the destiny
by someone else like a cover of it
whatever but then so I put the song on I
went into the shower and when I came out
I realized it was playing Lou combs
Lou combs radio oh and that's got her
Gabi Baird I heard all these and so
they've now it's a perfect now it's wait
that's great I did think that was a flaw
as well yeah like you're listening to
some random podcast that starts with
she's got yeah
great I'm so glad they're on top of it
now they're just doing songs that are
similar to the song that you choose
chose and so now it's like the world is
perfect the morning shows is also
available on Spotify if you wanna listen
to it they're just like choose between
music you can put it in a playlist yeah
and you can make like songs based on
I've heard from a lot of composers that
they prefer listening to the podcast on
Spotify because something about it
taking up less storage on your phone
yeah which I don't know if that to be
true or not but if it's true good for
them yeah love it sign on but that
wasn't an ad for Spotify yeah okay next
story bachelor Peter Webber scene at a
winery with his with the producer he's
rumored to be dating this is not a rumor
this is a baseless it's lies they're
literally working overtime to make us
think that he ends up with the producer
yeah like someone at ABC HQ saw the
theory going around they were like ooh
we like this this helps distract from
what's actually happening but let's sway
the audience you two are going to a
winery because we're gonna sit out in
broad daylight literally with nothing
covering you and we're gonna send a
paparazzi like it was so strategically
planned yeah because the first rule of
winning or being on The Bachelor is that
you can't be seen with the person that
you're with in public without wings it's
like Fight Club yeah also like I would
just really bet my entire life
that this isn't true yeah and even turns
out to be true like I swear like I I
will feel like I know nothing yeah I
wouldn't yeah it will turn everything I
thought I knew upside down but from what
I think that I know this couldn't be
further from the truth
like I can't believe it's even a story
that then now it's in page six like it
started just like this to be started on
Instagram just like with you know the
ants by the way they're literally doing
everything they can to like make this be
like a big big story
you know I'm saying yeah Alex
it's not yeah and this just make proves
to me that it's not right Lange said
they're going to to make it a story
proves to me that a time story Jackie
you are the smartest woman I've ever met
and I just think literally just said
that right before me so you're pretty
smart too I mean I'm a lot of things you
know stunning creative beautiful
obviously but I'm just like no she's
very good form under stunning totally
different because beautiful also is like
you're inside stunning is like totally
like a physical thing and I like the
action of being stunned it's more of a
physical thing it's what I do to others
what my presence does to others but you
know I'm like not smart and I never was
like I was never in like in school like
I never got good grades and like things
come to me really slowly like I like if
we're all watching a movie like shutter
island' where there's like this big
shock at the end like I won't get it
yeah I'm like not smart and I can't
remember anything I need a new brain no
but you know it's crazy as people think
that I'm really smart minded smartest
girl I've ever met but I growing up I
was not smart I didn't do well in school
I would work so hard just to get like
such a mediocre grade I just like things
would not click for me see I'm a firm
believer in being doing well in school
doesn't make you smart okay but so I
really feel like your life smart I'm not
talking about I feel like I wasn't I
guess you know you living you learn but
I wasn't always like smart like I just
wisdom comes my age I recently became
just like a wise old woman I guess when
I decided to be a grandma I just was a
grandma on the outside on the inside
yeah I don't really feel like we should
be like qualifying people's smartness
based on school because school is a
bunch of [ __ ] and I went to my high
school reunion and I saw those smart
kids and like a lot of them didn't even
have jobs so yes just lets me out it's
one thing to be smart but then to apply
the things that you know and be able to
make a life from it like that's that's
what separates the boys from the men so
Jackie you know okay next story
she's what separates the boys to men
James Corden reveals how much he regrets
doing cats on Justin Beaver's bill your
gut segment the headline is misleading
because the question on spill your gut
says how much do you regret doing cats
from a scale of 1 to 10 and he said he
had the best time he shot for 6 days
they were such fun six days six days and
he said overall he regrets doing it at a
4.5 so not that much it's not bad I feel
like what's to regret he got a ton of
press he probably made a lot of money
and he had six days of work and
got to become friends with Taylor Swift
I would have a zero regret just because
the movie stunk it sound like he was an
investor in the movie but it's a stain
on his record
it's a scene on everyone who participate
I disagree I think that like it's not
it's not good I think if it's gonna
stain anyone that's probably gonna be
Judi Dench because she should have been
above this but other than that it was
all these people who love music and love
musicals someone to be part of it no but
to me when I think of the cat's musical
and like the biggest perpetrators it's
James Corden and Taylor Swift Wow really
whether I know I know I didn't see but
like he's fine you know he is cats and
like it's done so well on Broadway
there's like he's at it was out of his
hands at this point
but when I think of the biggest people
who are associated with it it's James
Corden and Taylor Swift everyone else I
feel like I never got off scot-free
really I think Jason Derulo was a star
yeah oh really
Jason Derulo do you know Jason Derulo's
like a trained opera singer he's
everything of the soul so talented and
though he's so talented he's such a good
dancer he's such a good singer he is so
good-looking he's just I grew he has a
lot of money I hope he does I think he
does because he's not Thursday after hit
yeah cheating he regrets breaking up
with Jordin Sparks no I don't think so
but I would like to see him in a
high-profile relationship I'm ready for
that I'm ready for that for sure mm-hmm
I wonder how he's supposed to breathe
with no air it's really hard ya know
it's like the one thing you need to
breathe yeah people used to like give us
so much [ __ ] for singing on the podcast
and I feel like we've been singing a lot
recently but I don't think it's
bothering people as much because we have
my like these are like state of the art
podcast Mikey yeah which we didn't have
before so I think I'm just gonna keep
singing should I give this shot maybe
even I'll sound good hit it sis I'll
give you a beat ready there's always
gonna be another mountain I'm always
gonna wanna make it move always gonna be
an uphill battle sometimes I'm gonna
have to why ain't about out fast I guess
okay ain't about what's waiting on the
other side
it's the class that was like sickening
you know I have no clue so I should we
add myself we just for old times sake do
a good old-fashioned guest on oh yeah
let's see where we're at five six gasp
would I sound like I have notes when i
do that i think that that was perfect a
perfect harmony i think so they do i
don't know what our perfect harmony is
but i think that was it yeah you know
what's funny about harmonies i think I
told you this once but whenever I listen
to Lou Combs's song only him I sing
along at the top of my lungs but I
harmonize with him so um actually I
experienced something similar and I
don't think that your harmonizing with
him I think he has a very low voice and
we sing at the exact same octave but one
octave higher no but I really do think
I'm singing a different note you are
you're singing and say I'm think you're
saying I'm singing in a different
octaves yeah I think I'm singing like in
a different so here she got the best of
me she broke my heart
we're singing the same way okay you're
confusing me I just know that that's
what I do we need like a mute a vocal
profession like an expert to come on
this show and help us with our vocals
yeah okay we'll work on that
anyways uh James Corden said that he had
the loveliest time making that film
it took me 60s and I loved every second
of it so I think you've got to be
careful not to you've got to decide
things on your own personal experience
and I had a really great time yeah I
feel like it would be shitty of him to
like [ __ ] all over it because regardless
of how the movie did like it was
prestigious yeah totally someone said
their mom just walked in and she said
what are you listening to they have a
good harmony dead so that's all we are
we this Harvey for a second harmony yeah
okay fifth and final story a little bit
sorry oh sorry okay sorry I'm gonna with
my microphone I want full arm reign
range range of motion if you didn't find
a story a little is news also a little
fashion news and a little justice news
and a little modeling news before we
bring out Emily didn't Otto Victoria's
Secret is going private it is up for
sale and it's only worth one point 1
billion dollars and les Moonves is
officially out
yeah when and if the sale goes through
les will be Gone with the Wind fabulous
not
got it Victoria's Secret the troubled
lingerie brand owned by Elle brands is
being sold to a private equity firm in a
five hundred and twenty five million
dollar deal Sycamore partners in Elle
brands will split control of the brand
the private equity firm is buying a
fifty five percent stake while L Barnes
is taking control of the remaining 45
percent the Victoria's will be spun no
one calls it that CNN
Victoria's Secret will be spun off into
a fully private company the two
companies announced the deal Thursday
this is so crazy I feel like we're
really over the last year been watching
like the downfall of one of America's
biggest retail companies and I feel like
their downfall has nothing to do with
like the downfall of retail like all
retail Bonanza forever21 like everyone's
failing and that's because like online
is taking over
but Victoria's Secret managed to move
past like the fall of retail and they
were really so successful and their
downfall has literally nothing to do
with the fact that they're like a retail
chain it has to do with the fact that
they're deeply problematic yeah that
they just didn't evolve with the times
and what's crazy is I like even though
you know Victoria's Secret just has like
that leaves a bad taste in your mouth
right now there's still like maybe
thousands of stores tens of thousands of
stores and like it should still be worth
a lot of money right even the real
estate that it takes up you know but now
it's worth 1 billion dollars I feel like
that's how much third love is worth yeah
and to me like third love is responsible
for this in this way best way but I this
is not a sponsor for third love even
though they spoiler alert to sponsor
this show but like I feel like they
really opened my eyes to like how not
inclusive that it's like I'm not the
problem
yes that the people making the bras like
not all titties are just sigh equal yeah
totally
their love is totally like involved and
I also feel like I remember there was a
time when remember her Victoria's Secret
used to make swimsuits and like they
were everything sick and and then one
day they decided they were done making
swimsuits and they were gonna focus on
athleisure instead but I feel like
athleisure is such a saturated market so
many people do it so much better than
Victoria's Secret but we really are
missing those Victoria's Secret
swimsuits it's like yeah they hit a fork
in the road and they went down the wrong
way the two roads diverged in a yellow
wood and Victoria's Secret and les
Moonves chose to the road that was wrong
yeah
because I think that's the problem
actually I do shop in like the underwear
I'm wearing now or betray secret I
actually love their um I don't know what
it's called but they're like
at Gianni's I should get some before
they go out of business I never not
going they're still gonna be operating
but they're just being so I wear
exclusively hands underwear from Amazon
and I think that Hanes should sponsor
the show hit me up granny panties for
life for life okay should we bring out
Emily didn't Otto she's in the building
I'm very excited if you have any
questions for her and you're watching
live on YouTube feel free to drop them
in the stream um so we'll take a quick
break go get the snacks I had a family
here her thoughts on Victoria secret by
the way literally everything I have to
ask her is about Victoria's Secret like
I wonder if she have are auditioned if
she like stayed far away yeah if you
have any questions I feel like she's so
dynamic and I'm not thinking of
everything so drop a question in the
stream take a quick break go to the
bathroom we'll be back in a few minutes
with Emily didn't Otto die
we are back with our fellow model and
fellow toaster more importantly emilita
Donato who we've been trying to get on
the show for years yes and now you're
here I am so excited this feels like
destiny oh by the way you said you don't
do a lot of podcasts I don't are you
nervous I'm a little nervous because
it's live but at the same time like I
feel right at home
yeah and the by the toaster is love you
like they're so excited that you're
gonna be here I'm so excited I'm a
toaster and have been since day one so I
think the number one question we got for
you or are your eyes really blue they
are really blue these are my real eyes
yeah crazy they're so blue they're very
blue yeah but they don't work because
like I have a horrible horrible eyesight
and a horrible lazy eye so people are
like they're so beautiful and I'm like
they're great but they literally do not
work hey Emily did an auto supermodel
has a lazy eye it's severe relatable yes
what do you do about it
in pictures nothing I mean my left eye
just cannot go in the left direction
whatsoever really so oftentimes like
this is like not an optimal it like the
seating position cranked this way
otherwise my eyes would be crossed the
entire day if you had told us we would
have like switch with you I was like
ever Mariah Carey goes on watch happens
I've suit she has to take nd see it I
mean I feel like I'm not that no you are
that you are that you are that literally
I was on vacation in like the middle of
nowhere I forget where I was it was no
TV channels and I'm like scrolling
through and there's your face oh my god
that happened to me absolutely France in
a hotel with Zach me put on the TV and
was like a Sports Illustrated montage
and Emily comes on my six I know her and
exactly like you do yeah it was like a
slow-motion montage of Sports
Illustrated and I was like you're
welcome sorry I was amazing commercial
is that possible I was very possible
you've been on Maybelline you mean have
like the face and Maybelline for a
really long time I have for almost I
think I'm going on like 12 years which
I'm saying insane yeah I like hadn't
even gone to my junior prom yet when
they signed me and now I'm like married
in a full grown human yeah it's really
cool and I feel like they have seen me
go through like all of my life changes
and like growth and they've been so
supportive so that's a long time to have
that kind of realty also especially in
modeling yeah it's like it's I'm I'm so
so lucky I'm having so Yoli yeah but
yeah I can't even really are modeling
that
yeah genre like wow it's amazing well I
feel like I've known about you like when
we were in high school all my friends
were obsessed feeling like when you
willed it when it came to Instagram like
you were one of the first models that a
lot of us followed on Instagram way and
it's just very cool to see your arc like
you really grew up so gracefully like
you're married yeah first of all I can't
believe that that like you guys followed
me when yeah that's you were like an
Instagram model yes I did get on the
instagram game very early on I do recall
that I was like all upon there people
were like ooh I feel so weird about
taking selfies I was like you know
honestly was a genius marketing move
because now you know I'm just trying to
stay up with the times so hard has you
guys do a wonderful job with that you
take talk you know what I am absolutely
obsessed with tic-tac but I cannot
upload a frickin Tech Talk for my life
I'm terrified but I'm obsessed it's yeah
you start out like being obsessed with
watching it and then you're seeing all
these other people have fun and
eventually you're like I'm gonna learn
that dance you guys are doing a really
good job like yours are finally just
embarrassing ourselves good time but
that's just kind of fun about it it's
not something to be taken too seriously
jelly true to just let it be and have
fun with it which is why I really admire
people who are like really work out
there yes it's a dream job learning
those dances full-time job I dunno
renegade you do yeah ok we just learned
it it's hard it's really hard we can do
it later I'm sorry my first upload I do
have some followers on there um a really
famous one the other day was this girl
and she was like oh will you do a
tick-tock with me she was like I don't
event I was like okay sure like I was it
this one thing had a same name no no it
was like she was a German and then all
that I looked her up and she had like
three million dollars on tick tock days
like oh my god that's a big deal the
Tucker's really took over Fashion Week
this year and now Charlie's in Milan
with Prada
insane Addison was at the blonds in New
York I find it so fascinating are you I
feel like a lot of people in fashion
like might be averse to those types of
changes but are you open to it
no I'm open to it I mean it's like the
new up-and-coming coming young people
like I'm kind of into it and it's
interesting to see what happens next
with them and to watch them grow and
evolve being like tech stalkers but I'm
kind of here for it it's also like the
kids from cheer yeah and yeah cheering
takes
came at the perfect time because you
dance on tick-tock and you did once you
here watched here I haven't watched all
of it yet I'll watch like the first
episode but there are the bran and
Maxwell show and live okay we're viewing
that talk yes they were there and it was
so funny because there were like so many
important like special like fancy people
air and literally no one cared we're
kind of here for it I was I love it all
anyone cares about disrupting like a
very serious I really like it I do too I
like it too and I like that you know
Charlie jamali own these girls like
they're like natural normal yeah normal
it's not a bad word average like kids
and they adorable and it's like I like
that we're celebrating that kind of and
that's the new celebrity I feel like
people don't care about pop singers and
yeah I think it's not either anymore
yeah yeah I agree
I think it sounds a really good message
like if we were teenage girls and we had
like Charlie to look at to and like
she's not like full of makeup and she's
just being herself and she just makes
like being herself look fun exactly like
I was looking up to like Britney Spears
and Christina Aguilera and I was like
mom like why can't I wear a low-rise you
know now I feel like this is better
she's like in a sweatshirt doing cute
dance I'm here hold it and email the
literally sponsors tick tock I'll just
wear like cropped hoodies and shorts
yeah yeah um going back to Sports
Illustrated really quickly I feel like I
know a joke but I'm actually not a model
but if I was like I would want to be all
up in Sports Illustrated like the you
should be in the issue hi great you
should be thank you I know I know I know
someone oh you know yeah okay hit it up
I just feel like that's like the most
fun if you like the girls are all really
nice like they really celebrate a
woman's physique like it's true I love I
feel like I find out about so many
models
who's like my body goes like Kate Upton
like I only know about her because she
was on and I love Barbara Palvin like I
feel like didn't really get like a real
physique and I feel like that's like the
most fun brand to work with am i right
yeah it's true I feel like they've done
a really good job
I feel like Sports Illustrated did a
really good job because they were
celebrating like women of all different
shapes and sizes before it was I don't
want to say trendy yeah but they were
one of the first people like Kate Upton
on the cover and all these things I
don't think they put her on the cover
because she was this was like a cool
thing to write she was the right model
for the moment and a total and it
created this movement but I think they
were one of the first magazines to just
shoot women of all shapes and sizes and
it is so much fun to do yeah yeah [ __ ]
fun shoots because you're going in like
all these crazy exotic locations right
I've done it for years in the past and
then I just did it again this year I
shot oh yeah soon it comes out soon in
May yeah do you know who's on the cover
no we don't know who's on the cover
until it like launches oh really that is
how which every year it's always like
really because everyone of course wants
it to be them and then after it's not
you of course who disagrees but then
you're like no no it's cool like I'm
super grateful to be me that's so funny
because of course everyone thinks it's
sad like I bet I didn't even do a photo
shoot and I think that I'm in the cover
yeah like every I'm disappointed a
hundred that's so funny I just feel like
they do a good job of like fostering
like a fun environment honestly like
what Victoria's Secret was like supposed
to be and what they were like lying
about like we watch the show for years
and there's so much you know stuff
coming out about the company that I
would love to get your take on because
as someone who's actually the industry
like did you ever try out for the show
yes yes so I started modeling in 2008 so
as soon as I was old enough I was out
there like hustling trying to get that
show so I'll be totally honest about
that but it was a really big deal like
trust doing that show and being a part
of that brand was like the end-all
be-all like you had made it if you had
done that so yeah I probably to the
casting like three or four years in a
row but I never got it for multiple
different reasons and I understand just
like I didn't quite fit the mold at that
time right and yeah and then after that
after a few years I just decided to stop
going because I was like I am so amped
about this every year and I get so
pumped about it and like nervous and
then I leave feeling really really
horrible so then I just boycotted the
casting good my agents were like that's
a really stupid thing and I was like you
were ahead of your time I just don't
believe like like you didn't get cast
like if you don't get cast who does you
know I have never had ABS or like that
certain specific physique that I felt
like for a really long time I was like
the only thing that they were shooting
was this very specific mold of a person
that is like zero zero zero no bonus
yeah like I just have a little bit more
going on which I find interesting and
which is why I love Sports Illustrated
yeah I really support like their
movement it's interesting to look at
interesting to look at it definitely is
and I
like they've done a really good job they
were a men's magazine for so long right
and now it's like this crazy awesome
kind of more celebratory female yeah
it's like a female empowerment movement
too we've shifted in a really smart way
I think so it's nice to be a part of
brands like that and areas while I do
some work with yeah that's so nice right
like I'm totally aligns very much with
how I feel and what I think things
should be like do you feel like in like
earlier in your career you had to
sacrifice like how you feel just for
like friends you just like should have
worked with meaning today like know that
the things are gonna make me feel really
GART like horrible and because you
wanted the job yeah I mean I think in
the beginning I was hustling right like
I was like I want to be successful I
didn't go to college right away so I was
like if this doesn't work out and we
used super-embarrassed going back to
upstate New York and being like you know
I never mind I'm gonna join the
Community College that would have been
fine but I felt like I really like tried
to yeah
so yeah there were times where I was
like going out for things and I was like
this doesn't make me feel great but
maybe it'll really move the needle for
me and one way or another but I was
lucky that I had a couple of like really
great clients and jobs and contracts
that like allowed me to like stay sort
of current and working by yeah yeah but
then eventually you did go to college I
did go to Columbia for two years yeah
well what made you decide to go back to
school I think I had been modeling since
I was like 17 years old and I just felt
like I wanted to challenge myself and I
felt like I didn't know what I was even
interested in because I just all I did
was kind of wait for my next modeling
job and then I applied and I got in and
I just took classes in like a million
different subjects and it was really
weird cuz I was like 27 years old these
kids were like so young and they're like
why are you here and I was like I'm a
model but I felt like they were so young
and they were like okay okay like you're
a model I went to college and like there
was in every class like a token forty
year old like I actually remember being
in the lab with me with like an actual
80 year old but like and I definitely
thought it was weird but like if you had
rolled into my class like I wouldn't
have thought it was weird you look like
you're seven no no no I think it was
just funny I have the age difference and
also all of them were always I said that
something instrument a they're always
like watching Netflix and class and
stuff and what you're a fully formed
adult like I was just like wow that's
like such a waste of time yeah so
disrespectful
yeah that's funny so going as an adult
has its benefits like you have the plot
I want to take some questions from
Instagram from oh yes Ellie Cassady
Gray's ask her about her wedding play
it was perfect that's so nice I think
there's most interesting things that you
met your husband on a plane yeah Kim's
like I feel like that everyone's dream
you know how you go on a plane like like
being a little bit cute hoping to meet
someone what are the logistics of
actually fare like when do you get me
when do you get each other's names when
do you get really first-class we were in
business class oh I was wearing because
it was my first time going to Colorado
which is where we were going and I was
like okay it's going to be cold so I
were like ugg boots in a North Face
jacket and I was like this is I think
what people wear skiing I did not grow
up skiing anyway um and we sat next to
each other my husband was working most
of the time and I fell asleep for the
first half but then I like woke up
Midway and I ordered a sprite and he was
like did you just order a beer that was
his first
I'm so sorry Kylie he's gonna say that
and then I was like no it's a Diet
Sprite then we started talking and then
we had mutual friends in common we were
both from upstate New York
we lived across the street from each
other like we had all these very weird
things in common but I didn't think that
was gonna be the person I was gonna
marry I was just like what a sweet man
yeah yeah I think conversation totally
and I always talk to whoever sitting
next to me on a flight like I have to
know people that I keep in contact with
that I met on airplanes no way yeah
because I'm a Chatty Cathy on that
person you don't want to say that you're
like snitch I don't want to be stuck
with you in a long car ride you don't
let people sleep I'm just so curious
like I have a lot of questions for
everyone so the plane ended and then
what happened so then he was like oh we
were both gonna be in Vail he was going
for a ski trip and I was going for work
I was going to shoot the cover of Vogue
Australia so I was like shucks did you
tell him like it's nothing um I think I
kind of did but I also felt like when I
told him I was a model he was like okay
you're like a model right definitely
like right which is why I'm it's totally
valid and then I was like yeah just text
me but he thinks he's like so sly and so
cool and he was like because he gave me
or I gave him he gave me his phone I put
my number in and immediately texted
myself like Emily and he was like
clearly you wanted to hear from me like
right away I was like no it's like
purely logistical right like a nice
change of information exactly so yeah
that's so crazy so different I mean I
think you guys call a businessman bow is
that your ass he's totally and I agree
you always like I feel like you say
certain people need a businessman but
certain girls and I needed one really
yeah that's like it
he was he's totally being to my yang oh
my god it lives out oh sweet I just feel
like it needs to be made into a movie
I've never heard of anyway it's totally
a hallmark movie yeah I mean it's not
that romantic when I look back and think
of it because I was like snoring and
like ugg boots like what but I don't
only go up from there it's true yeah and
then from there we had like so many
great so did you guys meet up in
Colorado we did not so he followed up
many times and was like calling me Dad
strange like why are you calling yeah it
was literally like Kyle airplane like in
my phone
did you ever change it no I wish I
shouldn't Kyle airplane so true it's so
funny um and yeah he just kept following
up and kept calling me and I was like I
don't know why this man keeps calling
I don't text him and be like did you
just call him he was like wow this is so
annoying dad and then I invited him to
my birthday party like a month later and
I was like listen I'm gonna be in New
York cuz I had been traveling so you can
come if you want
he came with like twelve of his friends
and then after that we pretty much been
together since then Wow where'd you get
married in Colorado yeah because we met
there so that was kind of our spot so
he's right for you you know I felt like
I wanted my husband is much more
traditional so I tried to mix a bit of
more traditional with like myself which
I think I'm a little more simple and if
I had it my way probably would worn like
a slip dress down the aisle right when I
would show my husband pictures of that
he was like I don't look like a wedding
dress so I wore two dresses and I feel
like I hit both things I tried to it was
like all outdoors it was like more
natural and kind of simple and simple
colors but it was beautiful I loved it
was like the best day ever amazing
weather like Colorado's incredible yeah
I've ever seen the summer
never been I've been to Denver that's
color you guys yeah but that's not like
color yeah like in a city in Hyatt
you know yeah yeah okay from Christina
Lynn Yura Bay how did you feel
emotionally mentally and spiritually
after sitting next to Tyler see at a
Fashion Week show good questions by the
way we got over a hundred combat
questions and we only took nine and
yours made it oh my god come III knew
that was gonna make the mark politically
so guy he was on your show I was
I commented when you guys oh my god I
just get so excited were you guys very
like his vibe I was sitting right next
to him and he was so nice and such a
gentleman like I have to say he's
exactly what I pictured and what you
want him to be exactly and when you talk
to someone who also has such blue eyes
do you guys like see each other how did
that work I feel like I'm complimenting
eyes first
great great follow-up no nothing nothing
of the sort I just blanked out like I
was just like I'm gonna pretend like I
just pretended like I didn't know him
which I thought was the appropriate
thing it's respectful yeah because at
the end of the day I I dunno I know I
think I do and he was just so sweet and
so wonderful and so nice yeah like if
you wear it married he would have asked
you out um I don't know about that I
mean I like to think that he would you
need to yes okay next question from
syrup fetch what's your favorite
campaign you've ever booked and how was
the industry changed over the past
decade that you've been working my
favorite campaign that I've ever booked
was probably I did this really amazing
commercial for Armani aqua de Joie this
over fume that I feel like it's the only
it's like my claim to fame like it's the
only reason why anyone knows who I have
seen it oh my god you have to watch it I
feel like I know you from the Maybelline
and not two as well but I felt like both
of those things Maybelline and also this
particular commercial were like two
really big deals and like it was
everywhere and it really like put me on
the map and was just like very exciting
interesting how the industry has changed
was the ashen um well I feel like
obviously with social media things have
changed so much Instagram YouTube
tik-tok all these things but I kind of
like it and I think it's made fashion
and celebrities models all of it more
accessible to people which i think is a
good thing it's not so separate I think
it's good but yeah now it used to be
like you needed to know someone to get
into this industry and you it was kind
of hard to get into the city yeah now
with social media everything is
everything and everyone is so accessible
right and like someone who was just
sitting at home in their sweatpants the
next week can be at Fashion Week Addison
exactly I think I school I I do too I
think it's a good thing I don't think
everyone feels that way though
especially in the industry well they
have to get over it yeah he'll get over
it because there's you can't control it
yeah that's like that's like the comedy
and
stree like when people's podcasts just
become comedians like me but like but
like I feel like old-school comedians
don't like that but like you have to oh
my god yeah your show was incredible oh
wait yes it was so funny so funny
because you said straight guy Kyle in
the audience my name is Kyle I totally
forgot that like when I blanked out that
you were even coming and then I forgot
that your husband's name was Kyle and I
didn't even cut her but it was so it was
so cute oh you thought you were talking
to him okay final question from the
audience can you ask Emily about her
experiment aney Montana can you must
Emily about her experience with feeling
comfortable in her own skin in the
fashion industry you've been very open
about that and actually watched her
youtube video about me thank you
everyone subscribe to Emily on YouTube
it's pretty I wanted to ask you about
your YouTube channel oh yeah I mean I
felt like in the video that I posted on
YouTube what I said first of all I feel
like body positivity is such a hot topic
and all of those things but I think at
the end of the day you don't just like
wake up and say like I love my body and
I don't you don't it's like a daily
process and daily work and like daily
positive self-talk like sometimes you
just wake up and you're like and
sometimes I go to work and clothes don't
fit and people make weird comments or
they're like I don't fit into whatever
it may be
it feels crappy but at the end of the
day like it's just like that doesn't
mean that I am any of those things
really but I think it really comes down
to like you have to take responsibility
for your own thoughts and be like okay
you know what someone may have said that
or maybe I don't feel great but like I'm
gonna try to be positive and think about
all the reasons I'm grateful for my body
and how it looks and like in reality I
look great and like look really close
like it's it's not there's no point in
the negative talk must be hard for you
to get to that place when like literally
your job involves multiple people
talking about your body like literally
one person says one thing about my body
and I'll [ __ ] knock them out like
yeah literally your job it's my job but
also you become like so separated from
it like I'm like when people talk about
my body it's like I'm not inside of it
right because it's so like they're not
talking about me yeah they're talking
about they're trying to sell a
particular item of clothing or whatever
it may be so maybe they're like oh like
her butt doesn't look at her leg doesn't
look great right and I'm like I
understand like you're trying to sell
these like weird ass jeans and why I'm
not doing it right
so I try to like separate it and not
take it personally you have to remember
like what people are actually trying to
accomplish you what she has to key I do
not okay there was like a whole
conversation
about editorial versus commercial and do
you consider yourself editorial or
torsion you're both I think yeah I think
I'm a little bit more commercial but I
definitely had a little bit of a good
run doing more high-fashion stuff
occasionally I'll do a show and like
I've done many different types of Vogue
editorials and covers and like I got
super lucky but I definitely say I'm a
little bit more commercial but that's
another thing I feel like for a long
time people were like one versus the
other one rather than yeah yeah but I
think like Marshalls where the money's
at like that's why I write BNE yeah
but you're one of the few who really can
do both do you like walking and runway
shows I do because it's such an
adrenaline rush but it doesn't happen
and it doesn't happen that often for me
so I think that's why I love it so
special I think girls who do it a lot
it's like a lot going on for like it's a
fashion shows like literally ten minutes
oh and you're literally on the runway
for like 15 seconds it's a lot of prep
and fuss for something to tour but yeah
I do I like love it so much because it's
such an adrenaline rush yeah like it's
just not and all the time yeah okay your
YouTube channel which I started watching
because you posted that on Instagram I
feel like that was such an interesting
move what was the catalyst behind you
wanting to do that
you know I first of all thank you for
subscribing it's good everyone it's
great I appreciate it I started it
because I felt like with Instagram I
feel like no one knew who I really was
or what I sounded like and it was funny
even when I would do like q and A's on
Instagram people would say stuff like oh
my god like you're American like I
didn't even know you sounded like that
or you were like that so then I started
it because I felt like I had more to say
and to share and I do have this unique
access to like all these people in the
fashion industry and that's why I do a
lot of stuff on beauty because I have
access to all these talented people who
could teach other people and give this
accessibility that like I get to have
like direct access to by the way totally
my makeup artist text me today she's
like you're having emelita donato on the
show I'm like and she's endeavor said
that she was like I wish she told me I
would have come himself with her makeup
artists Erin oh my god she should have
caught know if she should have done my
makeup I tried to do it myself this
morning but yeah it's been really fun
and I feel like mmm it's really changed
like my career in like a in a good way
yeah you have such a like a strong head
on your shoulders I feel like having
your YouTube channel really opens people
up to learning more about you yeah and
it's nice because now especially in New
York or when I travel girls always come
up to me and they're like oh my god like
I follow you on YouTube like ba la
and I think that's so nice as opposed to
being like you're a model right like I
seen you in a magazine but people who
watch my youtube channel that's really
me like not you and they got me and they
I guess they liked it so and I really
appreciate that that people watch it and
that they're engaged in it it's a
totally different thing
so it's good Wow well everyone should
subscribe youtube.com slash Emily didn't
Auto right yes di gon ATO and follow her
on Instagram famous toaster lemme I'm
truly premium content Kyle really does a
good job of being a second husband he's
been working hard he's working on like
as we said like he's a businessman beau
it's not his thing he's not really a ham
for the camera but we have to love him
we have no choice but to respect that
yeah yeah okay well thank you guys for
listening to the morning to us we hope
you have a great weekend hunt the
morning trust streams live on youtube
monday through friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time so make sure to subscribe
www.youtube.com/watch morning toast if
you're watching live on youtube feel
free to subscribe to this video a thumbs
up leave a comment were also available
as podcasts and we're podcast be found
set Spotify iTunes stitcher Public Radio
radio cash box oh the places whoever you
choose to listen to podcasts find us the
morning show us leave a comment 5-star
review subscription about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are and how we
have such great guests thank you guys so
much of a great weekend ultra contrive
we'll see you on Monday